police in Phoenix are investigating a
possible sexual assault at a nursing
facility after a patient in a vegetative
state became pregnant and gave birth
CBS phoenix affiliate k Pho reports
woman gave birth to a baby boy shortly
after Christmas she has been in a
vegetative state for more than a decade
a spokesman for Arizona's governor calls
the situation deeply troubling and
promises a new focus on patient safety
Omar Villafranca is outside the hacienda
health care nursing facility in phoenix
omar good morning good morning there is
now police car stationed outside of
Hacienda Healthcare and family members
tell me that's the most security they've
ever seen here this facility is now
under criminal investigation as
detectives try to figure out who is
responsible a lot of people are mad my
family included parents of other
patients inside Hacienda health care are
furious and demanding answers
my heart hurts my chest hurts I haven't
been able to sleep good at night because
of what occurred here they're concerned
for the safety of their loved ones
after a female patient who's been in a
vegetative state for 14 years gave birth
sources familiar with the case tell CBS
Phoenix affiliate que pho the woman has
been a patient at Hacienda health care
for more than a decade after a near
drowning incident left her incapacitated
a source tells que pho she delivered a
healthy baby boy on December 29 but none
of the staff inside the clinic knew the
patient was pregnant until she began
moaning shortly before going into labor
when you heard about the news of what
happened here
everybody was up in shock Karina's has
seen as 22 year old daughter jasmine has
been a patient at Hacienda health care
for about two years now
Karina's not leaving her side you're
staying here 24/7 because you still
don't trust no trust has been broken and
severed completely while privacy laws
limit video surveillance in health care
centers says Sima says there needs to be
more cameras are there any cameras
that you see right now in the facility
none none not in the hallway no not in
the rooms of the nurse's station nope
nothing a federal database that tracks
nursing homes reveals Hacienda health
care has an overall rating of one out of
five stars according to state records a
staff member was fired in 2013 after
making inappropriate sexual comments
about patients Hacienda health care
declined our request for an interview
but in a statement says it's cooperating
with law enforcement and conducting a
comprehensive internal review of
processes protocols and people to ensure
that every single resident is safe even
though now it is a little bit better but
this should have been done prior to this
incident happening sistema is quick to
point out there are more good people
than bad people here at this facility
but there are also still a lot of
unanswered questions mainly how did
staff not notice that the woman was
pregnant when they're changing bathing
her and caring for her every day no
arrests have been made no suspects have
been named
bianna of course you will be following
this bizarre story but one thing is
clear as that family member said trust
has been broken and if you have somebody
in a Medicare in a facility you go to
medicare.gov and check that facility
against their database to see if there
have been any charges or rating problems
or any issues so a lot of questions
about that story but the main thing you
feel is just really sick and discussed
about that for the young woman for her
family or everybody involved and the
lack of cameras as well if there was a